now then arounds a relationship with
Britain and several other Western
nations has come under strain ever since
the United States withdrew from the 2015
nuclear accord last year and re imposed
its sanctions the UK seizure of an
Iranian oil tanker in Gibraltar was
followed by Iran's Revolutionary Guards
detaining least an attempt a row in the
Strait of Hormuz and of course Nazanin
Zachary Radcliffe remains imprisoned in
Iran since being arrested more than
three years ago to discuss that more I'm
joined by the Iranian ambassador to the
UK I Mead by dinner jad very good to see
you thank you very much to you for
coming along mr. ambassador may I ask
you first of all about these two tankers
we've got two impounded tankers is Iran
in effect trying to engineer some kind
of barter there the standard in Peru in
exchange for the grace one which is been
impounded in in Gibraltar
no of course resolution of one issue can
help the resolution of the other issue
but the question is there are these are
two separate issues which need to be
tackled separately because in fact the
the Iranian ship which has been seized
in Gibraltar has been a case of illegal
seizure by the by the Gibraltar
authorities no international regulation
has been violated by by the ship well
and the I want to carry on I remember
three but just continue with the
assignment I see you claiming that's
illegal but of course they claim and not
the claim the fact about the seizing of
the center in Cairo is that that was an
illegal act you know we would come to
that but the question is first on Grace
one as you know the EU has as the
regulation because now the United
Kingdom's referring to the EU regulation
in the EU regulation as you can see
there is no regulation restricting
export of oil to even Syria there is a
prohibition by European countries to not
all other countries that were you saying
yes European countries are interacted
not to import oil from Syria but
exporting oil even to Syria is not
banned for other things but it's
interesting what you're saying that mr.
Abbas
because first of all you are saying you
are admitting that it is bound it was
bound for Syria but those regulations
the EU regulations require any EU nation
that comes across a ship such as the
grace one in its waters breaking those
sanctions to seize it
it's not that's the interpretation which
is given by the United Kingdom which we
would not agree and incidentally the
European Union has been always in fact
not accepting the extension of its law
to other nations which is the
extraterritorial in fact extension of
the law so United Kingdom also part as
part of the European countries cannot
extend a regulation which is bound for
the European Union okay well they
interpretation coming from the Foreign
Office's is very different as you know
well let's get on to the standard
Imperial and the fact is that that was
an illegal act I mean that was sailing
in Omani waters when the Iranians when
your country boarded its endure has now
taken it first of all that ship collided
with a fishing boat in the area any
evidence of course of course
so the fishing boat was damaged and
there have been injuries the second
point is that this ship has entered the
Strait of Hormuz from the exit exit lane
which is against the law
it should come properly into the Strait
of horses on ships that allegedly
devalue any ship so how many of you
imperative it is there all this the only
one there are a number of such
violations which is prosecuted by the
Bandar Abbas court authorities and
normally these things can happen but the
question is that during this very hectic
time which we know that the the Persian
Gulf is in fact we have tension in the
region because of the US policies that
ship should have been very careful not
to violate such laws you're watching out
for that kind of thing weren't you but
let's say let's just look at its
positioning because this is the official
tracking in the Strait of Hormuz no
doubt you'd be
poring over that but the red dot in
effect clearly shows that the standard
imperial was in Oh Marny waters it was
not traveling in an illegal position and
and the fact is I put it to you mr.
ambassador straight up you've you've
taken it hostage to get some kind of
barter for your ship that's been held in
Gibraltar isn't that the strategy no
that's that's what the media tried to
say but the question is that as I said
the ship of steno in Peru has been in
violation of some transit regulations in
the area and they easily could that be
resolved there I mean transit
regulations it sounds like a like a
parking offence or something if you were
if you were driving don't they have to
pay a fine and you should let them go if
you're if you're driving and be other at
the other side of the highway yeah
that's a major offense we don't get
thrown in jail and particularly at this
very hectic time the ship should be very
careful in fact what I often tell them
they're very careful and you know get
the owners to pay or whatever's cheerin
and let it go the court needs to
consider that and maybe that solution
would be the decision of the court and
and it can be respected as you said
there are always offenses in the region
Court would consider and other in fact
they would either some financial
punishments some some punishments which
are in fact exerted by the law so there
are solutions but the question is that
in fact particularly this ship has
switched off the automatic
identification system for more than
hours so that in fact has done a lot of
damage to do you think it can be do you
think it can be sorted at would
releasing the grace won't help you so do
that does that have any bearing on their
on the status on the continuing
impoundment of the standard Imperial as
I said the resolution of one issue can
help the resolution of the help so that
would be a question is that
first we are very keen to see that
United Kingdom is doing all the measures
necessary to release as soon as possible
the grace one
and a former home secretary you know the
former Home Secretary Jeremy Hunt said
as long as it's not going to Syria you
can more or less have it back as long as
it sails back to Iran that is the
question because we announced very very
publicly at the at the early days that
this is this has not been this ship has
not been going to Syria so that well you
just tell me sorry sorry mr. ambassador
but sorry to interrupt but you tell me
in your first answer it was going to
Syria know that well I picked up on that
repeat I did too you know I said that
even even if the claim is that this is
going to Syria I was excited banned
activity but it's not going to Syria and
that was why was it going a signle sign
all the way around the Horn of Africa to
avoid the serious canal came into the
Mediterranean where was it going we are
not interested to announce that where is
going the question is that that was
claimed by the United Kingdom that it's
going to Syria and we said very clearly
that it's not going but she'll be
cleared up she tell us where it was
going I mean I can tell you one country
wasn't going to it wasn't going to
Israel was it where was it going it's
very clear and we have announced that
it's not going to the to a sanction
entity but for the business matters and
for the sanctions which are in fact
against Iran unlawfully we are not
entitled to say that what is the
destination of the ship okay
just I mean I used the hostage word
about their ships but of course almost
as concerning perhaps more concerning is
some is a proper hostage that Iran is
taken for three and more years and I'm
talking of course about Nazanin Sakaki
Ratliff I mean she's not a spy is she
she's in fact the question is that she
has been doing wrongdoing as she not spy
you know that espionage is a very
flexible language it can involve many
activities so you turn up with your very
young baby at that stage to see your
parents and your your professional
you're an international spy turning up
with your baby when you are engaged in
illegal activities it doesn't matter you
have a baby or not when you are engaging
in such illegal activities you should be
accountable to law so she has been in
fact tried in Iran and that's a
five-year prison which something that
has been given given to her the question
is do we want to help her to be released
before one Hale okay so if if that's the
intention there are some regulations
that should be followed we have a
clemency procedure and that should be
followed if you want to have nathangie
Langer McGill tube to be to be allowed
clemency in the fact that she's an
innocent woman being held by Iran who is
judging that she's innocent or not that
is a lady which has a donk wrongdoing
and that has been tried by Iranian Court
and this is the judge that judges that
she's in fact is not innocent okay and
she has done wrong so you think there
could be aware of some compassion let me
use that word instead of Tennessee it
could be shown do you think Boris
Johnson the new prime minister in the UK
is the man to do that because I know you
tweeted not to very long ago when he
became prime ministers saying as foreign
secretary he was the first one for 40
years or more to engage with the
Iranians so do you think that he's the
man that could sort this out I said that
the Prime Minister apparently is the
only prime minister in the UK that has
visited Iran personally and has had the
direct talks with Iranian officials so
as the foreign sector for mur foreign
secretary he knows the situation he
knows the the politics of Iran he knows
that how much in fact we can both of us
engage into a diplomacy to resolve the
outstanding issues okay and I just gotta
go see about one other gentleman of
course son hasn't featured large but
does feature large in Iran's future and
of course that's a president Trump now
you know that a year or so ago just
after they the Americans removed
themselves from the nuclear accord and
re impose their sanctions Donald Trump
said he would certainly be prepared to
meet with President rouhani with no
preconditions
is that something that Iran would like
to say we are not for in fact the camera
or in fact the media coverage we are in
fact at this very important period of
time we are very concerned about the the
policy of the United States which has
resorted to devastation in fact effects
into the region and in fact imposing
sanctions against Iran which has had
really effects on the many aspects of
the Iranian life on the on the patience
to receive in fact the medicine like the
chemotherapy in fact medicines and all
right but I've just got lastly I ask you
mr. ambassador why then given that the
pain you described there being called
caused by these United States sanctions
what are you a lien ating the United
Kingdom which is stuck by the nuclear
deal and is working with its current
European partners to try to keep it
together yet you seem to be pushing the
UK away by these acts
that's why vice versa we are expecting
that the United Kingdom as a partner to
the jcpoa which has been a very active
party in having this important
achievement of diplomacy would really
try its best to implement its
obligations under the nuclear deal and
also being able to arrange with other
partners to forcefully implementing what
we have agreed with in the nuclear deal